president's day is not only known as a
federal holiday but a day for some
really deep discounts too in fact after
black friday this is a day where
customers are looking for great deals as
retailers work to move last year's
inventory eight news now reporter sally
jamio is live near town square to tell
us if shoppers are still out there
searching for deals sally
denise i went all around the valley
checking to see if people were shopping
for these big sales and what i came
across was that business was per usual
some saying inflation
has caused them to think twice about
what they need and what they want
it is still a big shopping day trey
bodge is a smart shopping expert at
truetrade.com she says with many off
this precedence day retailers are
expecting click and foot traffic what i
am seeing uh in terms of what's
happening right now is that consumers
are
perhaps being a little bit more hesitant
to make a big purchase there's inflation
we're up over seven percent at this
point and so i i do sense a little bit
of hesitancy there badge says consumers
need to do a little extra work if trying
to find the best deals online there are
websites like couponfollow.com that
offer discounts you may not know about
bonj also says there are still supply
chain issues out there so delivery could
take longer than anticipated rebecca
sajak owner of little shop in the desert
agrees right now it's kind of hard to
get stuff in stock so we're kind of
unloading what we brought in for like
fall and winter and bringing in some
outdoor pieces floor models with up to
25 percent off and she isn't the only
one providing deals emily johnson is the
owner of for the love las vegas in the
arts district
she is getting ready for spring
merchandise we get lots of foot traffic
in here and we are doing a sale where
we're kind of getting rid of our winter
stuff so we're doing a buy one get one
fifty percent off even with the
inflation and things like that we're
still finding people willing to spend
money on like something that's really
good quality
now if you were shopping this weekend
you probably notice a lot of other
people too i spoke with jeremy aguero
with applied analysis with an update on
our economy he says we are exceeding
expectations in terms of recovery jobs
are up unemployment is down and taxable
retail speeding is up more than 20
percent percent this past year reporting
from town square sally jaramillo live
local now